A 4-
LINDHOLM PEELS OFF.
AS WE APPROACH THE 6 MINUTE  C.
WELL THE FLAMES GETTING KEEP IT
NOT ALLOWING THE BOSTON BRUINS
TO GET SET UP OR HAVE TIME TOS.
>> CASSIE: SO YOU GO BACK TAKE.
FIRED IN.GHT AGAINST SXEMD THE
CLIFFTON.
AND IT'S JUT A G FRONT.
OT THE
ONE-HANDER ON GOAL.
ULLMARK ABLE TO MAKE TWO
BACKLUND.
PASS IN FRONT DEFLECTED BY
PASS FOR RICHARDSON.ING. ANDER.
ACROSS THAT WAS INTERCEPTED BY
BERGERON.
DAVID
LOSES A BIT OF GAS HERE.
GIVES TEAM.
THAT'S IMPORTANT EVENTUALLY
LUCKY ON PATRICE BERGERON PASS,
I THINK HE'S LOOKING FOR THAT !
TKACHUCK WITH A GOOD  IN FRONT.
LOOKING BACK TO HIS RIGHT.
AT THE SAME TIME TRYING TO STAY
ON SEAN MONAHAN.
IT ACTUALLY TIPS OFF BODY.
TKACHUCK EVENTUALLY GETS HIS
PUCK TO NET.
ANOTHER PENALTY.
>> Rick: SEVEN SHOTS ON THE N
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THEY COULD
TEST T T
DYLAN DUBE EYE TO EYE WITH MAK
DEFENSIVE OWN LINE.
SHILLINGTON SAID YOU TAKES A S.
GETS BACK UP AND STAYS IN THE
BATTTT
HOOKS ONE IN.
ULLMARK SNAGS THATUCK.
PENALTY OVER, MONAHAN OUT OF
THE BOX, TWO MINUTES TO GO IN H
MANGIAPANE, GUDBRANSON,
COLEMAN, GLOVE SAVE, ULLMARK
CARRIES IN DEEP.
BEHIND.
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE LINE.
PUTS IT ACROSS.
ANDERSSON PASSALIVE.